prima è grande non solo sembra grande e
piccolo tutti benvenuti solito stories
oggi nuova challenge avevo già fatto
questo tipo di sale di 7 un po fa con
youtubers e personaggi famosi mi sembra
non mi ricordo comunque indovina le town
in questo sito dovrebbe essere
abbastanza difficile quindi sono super
curioso di vedere chi di noi fa più
punti è se riusciamo a indovinare l'età
di queste ragazze ragazzi anche voi
potrete giocare a casa assieme a noi vi
basterà scrivere nei commenti
il di rho appunto ragazza numero 12 13 e
voi scrive rete nei commenti prima di
sapere la risposta e poi vediamo se
avete fatto più punti noi forse abbiamo
fatto più punti noi o io o vitale
mettetevi comodi patatine pop corn e
l'estate un bella ex selezione delle
altri solberg assieme evitiamo allora
numero uno
questa ragazza secondo voi quanti anni
ha
ma questa è una persona famosa no sono
ragazze allora 14 15 16 17 18 e 19 più
di 20 io direi 18 allora secondo me
questo è un po un tranello perché ne
dimostra di più mai più piccola io dico
se di sì anche se sembra molto più
grande voi scrivete nei commenti ragazza
numero 1 età quindi tu dici
effettivamente la stessa cosa vedi netto
18 soc
ci mettiamo 16 vediamo 17 13 sì era
proprio in mezzo a voi siete riusciti
indovinare comunque 0 punti con 0 punti
allora questa ragazza quanti anni a 4
dischi senza 7 18 ce l'ho più di 20
io dico 15 io dico 14 sembra piccolino
anche se si sembra un po più grande però
direi 14 io non sono bravo con queste
cose numero 2 scrivete nei commenti
vediamo tanto ea voi avete indovinato
allora al numero 3 ma chi è questa la
kardashian
no non è una carta stagnola assomiglia
nemmeno cosa sembra già molto più grande
che non faccio abbiamo fino a sempre gli
stessi più 20 io direi mente di più si
di aspetto sembra più di 20
però non so se c'e qualche tranello
dietro però dai proviamo più di venti
voi scrivete nei commenti
ss 14 al via vediamo cosa 15 anni o più
io spero che ai ragazzi crescono molto
più velocemente però perché se non sono
ragazze qua bisogna vedere anche ragazzi
son ball 4 che continui a questa ragazza
sembra grande promessa tornante gli dico
16 anni servizi dai possibile 16
impossibile dai guarda il visto proprio
da donna voi cosa dite numero 4 scrivete
nei commenti
no io direi almeno 18 almeno nelle dare
i 22 23 ma almeno 18 vediamo quindi tu
dici sedici 16 di sotto quindi assurgano
17 anni veramente assurdo questo che il
disegno è una resa legno sembrano foto
immagino la foto di un nome scritto
droid droid
vabbè allora secondo voi numero
cinquantenni a questo disegno
secondo voi questo disegno a così pochi
io dico 18 il numero 5 vediamo da
impossibile vabbè comunque nel senso da
un disegno quindi non si capisce lo so
mi debbo questa sembra la cantante
camilla cabello questa gente o no lo
conosco so che somiglia molto comunque
il numero 6 che t'ha dato perché che
voto date bionaz perché età delle
rendite che ha vinto 15 dai compare
quindi la maglia per il piccolino ma chi
è
la donna e 15 anni ha giudicato scrivete
voi nei commenti secondo menia 17 almeno
17 cioè mostra di più però siccome sono
tutte così giovani io dico 17
ovviamente adesso non avrà 16 proprio
nel mezzo a questa schiappa allora il
numero 7 vogliamo anche vedere ragazzi
insomma ad allora che da questa ragazza
queste mister i quali anche un viso più
piccolo si sembra meno
io dico che una certa 16 anni ma io
direi anche 15 o anche se comunque ne
dimostra il più comunque però siccome
sono tutte un po tranello io dico 15 o
vediamo poi cosa dite scrivete nei
commenti
gli diamo proprio io mio dio veramente
rimango scioccata
allora numero 88 rimettere i commenti
quanti anni a questa ragazza allora
questo non sicura che piccoli
questo difficile ma io direi dai
commissari spostata 15 anni e anch'io
volevo dire quindi se quindi direi 14
vediamo perciò tanto tanto tanto tanto
cosa quindi ce l'ho pregata ma grande è
la risposta era più di venti e non
sembrano puntate tutto il contrario
proprio non lo so comunque rimaniamo giu
contento che sono fregato proprio una
grande allora questa stessa sembra
piccolina biotipo 15 anche io dico 14 è
l'unica che sembra tante piste così le
altre a partita adesso questa ne avrà 42
vediamo gli dico 14 tu quindi sedato
pubblichiamo
[Musica]
e allora il numero 10 10
lo ha detto prima numero nome
quanti anni a questa ragazza dai dirlo
provato 17 sì direi sui 16 17 io dico se
di sabrata e finiamo 15 no vabbè alcune
sono scioccanti veramente allora numero
11 traverso sono tutte delle bellissime
ragazze modelle supermodelle wow
allora non sembra sembra molto giovane
comunque no non bra una donna adulta ho
visto molto sviluppato comunque sembrano
con una doccia nelle dare più di 20 io
se però siccome sono queste modelle se
qualche tranello direi 19
vediamo tu sei lì si dice parso naturale
allora numero 12 questa ragazza sembra
più grande è decisamente sì vorrei più
di 20 voi che dite scrivete nei commenti
io dico più di lenti vediamo io 19 da
cosa è successo
poi la mia ho veramente anche questa
ragazza sembra che ne abbia più di 20
no questo giovane è solo il trucco c'è
di nuovo indice no io almeno 18 15 15
ovviamente voi nei commenti
questo numero durissimo sito dice il
ricco 18 che quindi ci risiamo
questo giovane si 14 sì anch'io dico 14
persone organi 832 allora scrivete
quelli commenti oggi si è fatta padre di
sfighe numero 14 anche nei 14 scrivete
voi nei commenti
vediamo tant è
diciamo una attrice di disney channel
giusto anche cantante di sempre e
comunque si vede che dopo 17 molto 15 ma
come hanno messo i numeri li hanno messi
così a caso io dico 17 si no 17 vediamo
quest'anno numero 14 15 allora purtroppo
non abbiamo trovato i ragazzi purtroppo
non capisco perché sono tutti di ragazze
questi indovinare età come però abbiamo
una stazione celebrities quindi quanti
anni a chris pratt
no non è un attore 32 32 35 41 beh direi
32 sembra proposito giorno
comunque questa è l'età riferita quando
hanno fatto le foto non è che hanno
fatto la prima e poi vecchiato quindi
quando hanno fatto questa foto aveva 35
anni portati molto bene qualche mia
christina hendricks 33 36 39 20 io cosa
33 non sembra tanto grande tu dici 40
addirittura vogliamo soddisfare roberto
addio
quanti anni a kanye west che espressione
allegra 29 35 33
sì anche secondo me di grande secondo
voi scrivete kanye west età chi è un
altro punto per me contiene ariana
grande arriva un grande non solo sembra
grande a picco allora io mi ricordo
hanno aspetta prima di lo tu non lo so
come per il numero prima lillo zagari
numeri borsa avrà 17 18 però sembra
sempre più piccola io mi ricordo che ha
un'età molto simile alla mia non so se
proprio lo stesso anno allora le opzioni
sono 17 18 21
questo foto io direi 17 sembra giovane
legali 21 proprio perché mi ricordo che
le tasse
però questa foto un po per chi a perm e
14 quindi direi in ventuno i motori si
sembra più piccola niente punto per me
quanti anni sa bene dic
benedict cumberbatch sembra giovane ma
non lo è però è inglese lui se non mi
sbaglio quindi potrebbe essere il
contrario anche tu dice il giovane però
per questo male 30 38
oddio adesso il porta bene di tutto il
bordo molto loro quartieri alle amiche
leo mi fu quella di blair allora 25 28
30 28
anche secondo me vediamo ogni anni kim
in ansia
allora questa radio voto anni fa no è
stato tenere 2014 quattro anni fa
[Musica]
26 28 31 ott i 20 film 18 blog
non lo so proprio si può esser 28 31
cavolo ho io la di caprio e questo solo
tu lo sai sicuro perché dopo saperi che
so che piaccio come attore è un per
questo mattone e quindi cosa fai da te
sei fan
38 40 42 allora 38 è abbastanza giovane
comunque perché è stato rifare grave
piccolissimo però questo barbaro
invecchia un po sì diciamo 38 40 nuovo
cioè se li porta bene quindi avevo 2018
né a 44 cammino di josé anche le
indefinibile non ne ho idea
sicuramente si riposano un brano di 28
30 al 33 mo mazziere così attraverso
pensavo di più forse 33 sì come di più
tu non lo so porta bene chi mi ama
maggio un nuovo no scopo la conoscete 29
35 40 35 29 pochino direi 35 ma potevo
più giovani quanti anni a josh
hutcherson che dovrebbe essere quello
degli hunger games sembra piccolissimo
22 24 28 24 24 7 22
poiché madonna ovviamente conosciuto 50
definibile perché comunque un po di
chirurgia in viso quindi un po difficile
da capire però sicuramente si tiene
molto bene e 50 56 e 58 56 56 e quindi
se di quattro anni fa adesso c'è una 60
anche mia john krasinski
non c'è da qualche parte ma non mi
ricordo ma sente un fisco meno colto e
tanto vento
[Musica]
katy perry 26 28 39 pareggio ma di cui
30 michael cera o celebre sera del 23 25
26 23 26
eva mendes 30 41 36 40 o si tatti 4 e
non emotivi come ha fatto a rimanere
così 40 anni
obiettivo vv fantastico ansa 29 32 e 34
34 32 di lotta 4 abbiamo grande gravità
n'è innamorato di bryan cranston usare
preferito allora senza guardare visto
che sei un grande fan
quanti anni ha 98 in quanto agli ne
avrei dato più di quarantotto viene da
rischi
tendiamo lo so non ne ho idea 51 55 58
io direi sconcio vediamo una incredibile
si riporta bene no moto ma kristen bell
29 30 34 tu si che dico 31 sempre a
picco la 34a crisi porta visivo will
smith 40 43 46 forse 46 rosa tanti non
sembra ho indovinato rihanna 26 29 31 31
forza dei 31 serio
no non me l'aspettavo proprio che fosse
così giovane ok poi molti di voi che si
stanno guardando che hanno tipo meno al
quindi voi hanno meno di 14 anni
penseranno maggiore giovane 20 meglio
allora fateci sapere quanti punti avete
fatto noi ovviamente abbiamo perso il
conto però forse io se voi avete preso
il conto dei nostri punti fa suscita
pareri commenti fatti si sa per esempio
voi siete stati imbrogliati o se siete
bravi a dominare le tasse volete sistici
voi
secondo voi noi quanti anni abbiamo se
non lo sapete quanti emilio molti anni
abitante nella notte se non lo sapete
scrivetelo nei commenti vediamo chi
indovina hackett a sfidate oddio e ora
vi lasciamo bar quattro casse dire sub
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
video divertenti challenge cliccate su
quella che preferite buoni punti